who doesn't love a party right a lot of
us jump at the chance to leave all of
our troubles behind and get together
with friends and family for a good time
celebrating a special occasion while
unencumbered by the weighty
responsibilities of everyday life
parties give us an excuse to kick back
to meet new people as well as catch up
with old acquaintances and mark a
holiday or someone's birthday in the
most memorable way possible or at least
they can be when you're one of the
guests invited to a party when you
happen to be one of the poor souls
tasked with organizing one they can
change from an exciting and much
anticipated social gathering to a
dreaded time sink of organizational and
logistical chaos can you tell i needed
to organize 05-1's 141st birthday party
recently i'm still recovering from the
stress but i'm not the only one
suffering from this particular kind of
anxiety for a young man named alex
planning an upcoming shindig was turning
out to be that particular kind of
absolute nightmare that anyone who has
ever tried to organize a party will be
all too familiar with it had seemed like
such a long time away when alex had
first drawn that short and oh so unlucky
straw two months on paper sounds like
forever plenty of time to get everything
ready but the list of jobs that needed
doing before the dreaded party date only
seemed to get longer and more
complicated with each day that passed
you see normally alex thrived at keeping
himself organized every part of his life
usually running like clockwork the trick
as he found was to pay attention to what
he could control naturally in life the
unexpected usually tends to happen but
alex had learned that by regimenting his
daily routine having specific times for
certain tasks and scheduling the week's
events on his calendar he could keep
himself pretty on top of everything it
was that organizational mindset that
meant that alex's friends decided to
nominate him as the sole planner for an
upcoming surprise birthday party of
course being organized and in control of
one's own life goes completely out the
window when trying to coordinate all the
various moving parts needed for a party
it had been left up to alex to sort out
when this celebration was going to be
held along with who would be attending
the entertainment food and drink setting
up group chats to update everyone along
with a whole cavacade of other important
party factors each one fraught with its
own potential problems from the
beginning it was an uphill battle the
first venue alex had booked had to
cancel the whole building needed to be
fumigated because of a rat problem
guests were rsvping at a sporadic rate
some would confirm their attendance only
to back out days later with the party
day drawing closer and closer the
planning had become a perfect storm of
problems that were all out of alex's
hands in an effort to regain some
control he raced out only a week before
the party stocking up on finger foods
and beverages that were all extremely
overpriced but by now the party was only
a few days away and alex was acting in a
blind panic you see it was in that panic
that he reached for something throwing
it into his shopping cart without fully
thinking about it it was a pinata a
hollow paper mache animal designed to be
filled with candy and hit with sticks
until the contents burst out sure it was
a childish party game and in the back of
his mind alex wasn't sure why he'd
picked it up maybe part of him thought
everyone would find it amusing a bit of
quaint nostalgic entertainment he barely
noticed how it didn't even seem to
resemble any known animal and was
instead shaped like a strange cross
between a unicorn and a llama alex was
too lost in everything else he still had
to do to think about the pinata for too
long his biggest mistake was deciding
not to put it back in the corner of the
party store where he'd found it
arranging for the surprise to take place
at one of his friend's houses alex's
party seemed to be coming together at
long last but still he was in a state of
panic with only a rough estimate of how
many people were going to be there and
no clue who might show up or not
gradually the guests filled in and the
more of them that did arrive only caused
alex further worry that he hadn't bought
enough food and drink much to his
frustration a few who had cancelled
managed to change their other plans last
minute and made it despite saying they
wouldn't be able to despite everything
coming together the whole event still
felt like an unmitigated disaster even
after the guest of honor arrived the
surprise was sprung and the evening was
in full swing alex's brain was still in
organization mode if a drink got spilled
he dashed in and mopped it up to avoid
any lasting mess the same happened if
food was dropped or chairs were knocked
over truth be told it was actually
stopping alex from being able to enjoy
the party he'd spend so much time
organizing that's your problem man milo
one of his friends told him this is a
party stop trying to control everything
stop worrying you never know you might
just have some fun tonight
i suppose you're right alex sighed to
reply
no way you got a pinata milo spotted the
brightly colored animal covered in what
looked like tissue paper instantly alex
felt embarrassed that he'd picked it up
fully expecting to be a laughingstock
for bringing it to a party surely
everyone here had outgrown a party game
like that and yet to alex's complete
surprise minutes later his friends were
taking turns being blindfolded and
swiping at the pinata with a bat trying
to break it open so its candy contents
would come spilling out as he watched
milo take a huge swing and miss the
pinata by a mile alex couldn't help but
laugh not even noticing himself relaxing
and enjoying the night's celebrations
soon enough it was alex's turn to be
blindfolded eyes covered spun around
unable to see anything but total
darkness he took a wide swing at the
pinata miss pulling back the bat spurred
on by the chorus of his friends laughing
around him he gave it another go this
time he felt the hit the vibrations
traveling down the bat and into his
hands told him that it connected aiming
blindly for that same spot alex gave
another swing this time with much more
power behind it certain he'd break open
the candy-filled cardboard creature the
bat connected again hard enough to knock
the pinata off the string keeping it in
the air hearing his friends cheer and
whoop alex lifted the blindfold to see
the pinata lying on the ground a few
meters away then turned to the group
around him one more to break it open the
ass met with laughs and nods of approval
lifting the vat again alex brought it
swiping down towards the pinata with he
was sure enough force to break it open
but as he struck it something strange
happened or rather what was strange was
that nothing happened the pinata still
didn't break it shouldn't have been
possible after all alex was sure it had
only been made of flimsy cardboard and
paper mache the whole thing should have
come apart by now and yet the bat had
lazily glanced off the pinata the
inanimate animal seeming to resist the
oncoming bat as if it were nothing by
now the other guests at the party were
looking somewhat bemused at alex they
too had been expecting the pinata to
break and a shower of candy within to
come spilling out not wanting to lose
face alex made the instinctive decision
to take one final swing at it only to
find he couldn't his arm wasn't moving
it had less than 30 seconds ago he'd
been able to lift his arm but now it was
rigid locked in place alex's lower body
was in much the same state unable to
move as if his feet had been stuck to
the ground legs too stiff to take a step
the only part of his body alex could
still move were his eyes which now
darted frantically over the faces of the
party guests their looks of bemusement
or excited smiles were all rapidly
washing away into stairs of confusion
and concern some of his friends started
asking what was wrong but he couldn't
reply when alex tried to speak his jaw
stayed clenched shut teeth pushed
together so hard they might shatter
tongue and tonsils frozen still some of
the guests drew closer waving hands and
clicking fingers in front of alex's face
trying to elicit some kind of movement
from him a few thought it was a joke
waiting for him to suddenly move and
shout and frighten them for a cheap
laugh all the while alex was trapped in
his own skin
locked in a body that had somehow become
a prison the moment he'd step closer to
the pinata his eyes caught sight of milo
dashing into another room and returning
with a phone in hand he punched in three
numbers to call the emergency services
although it did little to calm the
rampant internal panic alex was feeling
the paramedics arrived at a record speed
by the time the ambulance pulled up at
the house most of the other party guests
had either stepped back from alex still
standing frozen in place or had left the
party altogether as the emts rushed in
and started asking if he could hear them
or say anything alex tried with every
ounce of strength to get his mouth to
move yes he wanted to say to scream just
to let all the mounting panic out i can
hear you i'm awake i'm in here i just
can't move
despite their best efforts the
paramedics couldn't get alex to move
instead trying to lay his rigid body
down to begin cpr one of them gripped
his hands together about to start chest
compressions while everyone still at the
party watched in silence the paramedics
gently pushed down on alex's chest when
just like the pinata it burst open for a
microsecond alex's eyes widen in pain
and shock before rolling back his chest
split as if it were made of paper mache
instead of skin and bone inside where
his lungs should have been was a pile of
candy the party didn't end with a bang
that night but with a horrified scream
later that night after the rest of the
party's guests either fled home or were
urged to leave by the confused
paramedics the police were called to the
scene roping off the room where the
apparent accident had happened although
curiously it seemed that the pinata had
somehow vanished maybe someone removed
it after all it's not like it just got
up and walked away right meanwhile
alex's remains were taken to the local
mortuary and handed over to the
pathologists for an autopsy they noticed
despite only having died recently the
body seemed to be severely dehydrated to
the point where the limbs the outer skin
and various internal organs were brittle
the pathologists that examined the body
made another startling and confusing
discovery when they opened up what was
left of alex more candy was growing out
of his organs there were over a thousand
sugary pieces each one individually
wrapped in unmarked foil without any
logos or branding needless to say the
pathologists examining alex's corpse
were understandably left baffled they
had never seen anything like this in any
cadaver barely able to come up with a
cause of death how had his body gone
rigid and left him completely unable to
move how had candy been able to start
growing from his internal organs and
most importantly who or what had done
this to alex well here's what happened
something that alex had presumed to be
nothing more than a harmless party favor
filled with delicious treats was far
from just an ordinary pinata you see it
was actually an instance of
scp-956 although we can hardly hold alex
entirely at fault for assuming there was
nothing different about this particular
pinata on the outside as
cp956 does appear to be an unassuming
cardboard creature made of paper mache
or at least that's what it feels like
it's made of but the surface of scp-956
is actually constructed of
unidentifiable fur glue sugar and most
unnervingly human tissue scp-950
is an entity that normally remains in an
inactive and docile state displaying no
intelligence or active hostility at
first glance you wouldn't even know that
it can move unlike any ordinary pinata
you might buy at a local party store
which are designed to break upon impact
scp-956 manages to maintain its
structural integrity against most forms
of external damage whether bludgeoning
it with a bat or applying crushing force
with fists or kicks the pinata will show
virtually no change in its state the
only effective way to leave any lasting
damage is through the use of flames or
gunfire and you might have a hard time
finding any of those at your average
pinata party however when an unwitting
human victim comes within a 5 meter
range of scp-956
and for a long enough time the entity's
further anomalous qualities will
activate the pinata will render its
victim totally paralyzed from head to
toe diminishing their motor functions
and leaving them unable to move any part
of their body say for their eyes this
doesn't kill the victim however just
immobilizes them they retain full
awareness just like alex did but can
only helplessly look around while being
unable to flee and why would they need
to flee well because once it has frozen
a victim that's when scp-956
begins its approach the pinata will
switch from being an inanimate object to
a creature capable of movement and
proceeds to physically attack its
immobile vulnerable human target it
doesn't stop continuously bludgeoning at
the victim until eventually their chest
ruptures and a pile of candy comes
tumbling out like an avalanche as for
why
scp-956 didn't try to attack alex this
way maybe someone else at a party
knocked it aside without noticing or
perhaps the paramedics managed to make
it to the scene before the pinata had
its chance whatever the case the candy
produced by a victim of scp-956 seems to
be formed using their internal organs
and bodily tissues it is unclear how
quickly this candy begins growing after
a person is exposed to the pinata
however it appears that the amount of
candy produced is dependent on how much
time the victim spends in close
proximity to scp-956
the longer they're close to it the more
pieces of candy come spilling out when
they're opened up as for the candy
itself commonly referred to as cp 956-1
as you might expect it's far from
anything you'd buy in an ordinary store
and its negative effects aren't just
limited to toothache or sugar rush the
pathologists that performed alex's
postmortem were lucky none of them made
the grave mistake of actually eating any
of this cursed candy if they had they
could have experienced violent seizures
upon consuming the sugary confectionary
within three minutes the candy that had
come bursting out of alex's insides
would have made a person drop to the
ground unstoppably convulsing with a
chance that they would also experience a
potentially fatal cardiac arrest animals
will usually also suffer these effects
upon eating instances of scp-956-1
in humans however the effects of the
scp-956-1 candy seem to vary in most
cases those who consume it will
experience the aforementioned seizures
with an additional five percent risk of
heart attacks but other instances have
shown an entirely different side effect
that somehow manages to sound even less
appealing the second of the candy side
effects begin with a process very
similar to the immobilization caused by
exposure to scp-956
a person after having consumed the candy
will lose control of their body's motor
functions becoming unable to move
however the first key difference is if
they remain in a standing position with
their arms resting in front of their
body the next is the rapid and grotesque
sequence of bodily changes that follow
firstly their hair rapidly begins to
fall out shedding in clumps until it is
replaced with paper mache that grows
over every inch of skin next their bones
and muscles are forcibly rearranged
crunching and contorting unnaturally
until the affected person can no longer
stand the same way they used to in fact
by that point they aren't a person
anymore within 9 minutes of eating the
scp-956-1
candy they will have been transformed
from a human being into a pinata from
that moment onwards they are another
instance of
scp-956 as you may have already guessed
the foundation has done us all a service
by rounding up existing instances of
scp-956
and all the candy produced by the
pernicious pinata and that is a lucky
thing too for any of you would-be party
planners out there after all nothing is
harsher than coming to a celebratory
atmosphere than a pinata that fills
people with human candy that comes
bursting out of them just ask everyone
at alex's party although maybe it'd be a
good idea to avoid buying a pinata for
your next get-together just to be on the
safe side now go check out
scp-2003 preferred option and
scp-3790 department of abnormalities for
more stories to frighten the life out of
your party guests